okay all right Heather you know I can
take mice spiders I could even handle
snakes Okay I can't handle creepy scary
ghouls and goblins at so this kind of
stuff is no good stuff no good all right
Sherry's got a limit I don't know about
mine we're gonna see because I'm gonna
go to a haunted house tonight so but
there are so many ways that you could
put your fear to the test and one of
them is Tivoli Village Fear Factory has
four attractions Candace Charles joining
us live with a look uh Candace some of
it's family friendly
[Music]
or not it is but you know what you guys
I believe I've become a Halloween
haunted house Pro I guess we're going to
see right now put that to the test yes I
am in one of four attractions here at
Fear Factory Las Vegas and I'm joined
with one of the great minds behind it
Derek Hagen thank you so much for
joining us okay I'm a little nervous
I've been sweating a little bit but I
think I'm ready which one are we in
right now we are in the zombie escape
which is a multiple chamber zombie
themed experience so you've got like a
furnace yeah a freezer section a toxic
storage area a mad lab a research area a
swamp so it's all zombie themed and the
zombies populating the entire area and
they're here to scare you I'm looking
out for them right now you guys and I I
can't see yeah oh my gosh I can't see
them but
um there are other other things here
that are a little bit I guess less scary
really gotta test on your scare level
here there's something for for all ages
at least ages starting at eight tell us
about the other attractions well we've
got the Museum of monsters which is not
scary it's kind of a wax museum
experience you get pictures of all these
famous movie and TV horror characters I
think your social media platforms then
we have an ax throwing experience with
kind of a zombie flavor too let's try
that out next time I'm pretty good and
then we have like an Esports area for
video gaming so there really is
something for the entire family to come
down and enjoy awesome awesome and the
tickets start at 20 bucks there are
quite a few deals as well which is
really cool but something else is
children eight and two young adults 18
can get it for free how does that happen
well it's sponsored by stride education
so if you have kids between the ages of
8 and 18 if they come in and they sign
up and with their email address they get
to experience all these attractions for
free so awesome well it sounds like it
is a great time and thankfully
um I'm still alive I'm still hanging
Derek thank you so much for chatting
with us this morning thank you you guys
can find out more details and get
tickets and everything on our website we
got you covered with all of that of
course you can enjoy this every day
going Halloween from 5 to 11 o'clock I'm
gonna try to get out of here because I
am a little nervous but I'll talk back
to you guys oh my God we're laughing
because we're not in there wow that's
how I handle fear is I laugh you know I
just I have to laugh otherwise forget
about it you guys are jumping out okay
oh okay all right she handled it with
Grace I have to say we've got a whole
list of Halloween happenings for this
weekend and Monday night it's pinned to
our home page at eightnewsnow.com just
scroll down and it will be on the right
side of your screen because there's so
much to do and so much to choose from
you're gonna have to Choose Wisely I
feel like Candace is either a very good
actress and is acting as if she's
frightened or we really need to talk to
her about trying to find some live shows
that don't terrify her all the time no
she's going to be excited when Christmas
gets yes it's